you audition for friends yes and you
didn't get it and it's a heartbreaking
story you put your audition on tape
and you mailed it into the people at
friends right you sent it I was doing a
uh uh it's only heartbreaking to me no
it's heartbreaking for me the world got
got Chandler Bing by Matthew Perry which
was I think a work of Genius
heartbroken I however did but don't you
think you could have been a good
Chandler Bing honestly I think I could
have been a decent one I don't think I
would have been at the level of Matthew
Perry I I on some level the and I talk
about this in the book that that when
you audition for something and don't get
it
it's only when you see somebody do it
not well that you get mad I don't get
mad when when I see a an actor hit it
out of the park it's like well of course
no wonder they gave it to that guy I'm
so glad you said that because I've asked
a million actors that same question I go
what happens when you don't get the
movie roll and then you go to see the
movie and a lot of them say we don't
even go to see the movie but but if you
go to see the movie and the guy kills it
yeah does it just like does it just
break your heart no it doesn't at all no
it's exactly the opposite and and for me
like I auditioned for Reservoir Dogs
right which uh was uh which you wanted
to be Mr Pink yes yes uh and well no
they wanted me to be Mr Pink what
happened was I I uh I was flying to New
York on a Saturday and I got this script
right before I got on the plane and they
said uh they want to meet you on Sunday
it's the only day that this that this
young director can meet with people in
New York and that's the only day you
have to do it and I goes on the plane
and I tried to read the script but if
you saw the movie it's all over the
place and you're like what is what are
these people talking about and who what
there was a robbery but then they're
cutting an ear off there's no script
there what is going on here right there
actually is a great but it's very
complicated but it's very complicated
and I just couldn't handle it on on
flight 007 going into to JFK so I read
as much of it as I could but I I
couldn't finish it and uh uh and I
thought oh God I'm gonna go into this
thing not really prepared and uh the
next morning though I get this call from
my sister that uh that her uh her
mother-in-law is ill she's got to go out
and visit her in Long Island and so can
I take uh her daughter uh can I take
care of her daughter and I go oh oh I
have a good reason that I can't go to
this audition now
goodness so I call up the producer and
I'm like I'm sorry I can't audition for
this thing uh and he's like please
please we really want you to come in and
uh and I was like haven't you got this
whole monologue what is he talking about
Madonna it's hard to follow it's hard to
follow and uh and finally I just had to
beg off and not audition for and then
being a brilliant movie what did you did
you go see the most Steve Buscemi of
course
and he's great and the nice thing for me
is that I know that I that that uh that
I wouldn't have got that part even if I
showed up you think so I really don't I
truly don't believe I would have well
you know uh you you say that but who
knows and and you're a really good actor
and I think when you see Steve Buscemi
gets it and then you see it was a great
movie that's just such a horrible part
of show business I couldn't handle that
um did you go to the theater to see the
movie I did I'm curious I was curious
and uh and I was blown away and uh uh
and I you know I was mostly mad at
myself for not getting the script well
that's a good lesson yeah
foreign